Colin Farrell's transformation into the Penguin
caught everyone by surprise – even his co-stars
in "The Batman."
He spent hours in the make-up chair, and so
much more.
Here's how he made that intense transformation.
If you went into "The Batman" without knowing
anything about the film, you'd probably be
surprised to learn that Colin Farrell is actually
in it.
In "The Batman," Farrell plays just one of
multiple antagonists going up against a Batman
who's only been on the job for two years.
That's when a mysterious figure called The
Riddler begins leaving dead bodies around
town with messages for the caped crusader.
Farrell's depiction of Oswald Cobblepot, or
the Penguin, is already earning praise from
critics and fans alike, and Warner Bros. has
thrown their support behind the performance
by announcing a Penguin-centered spin-off
series for HBO Max.
"Whoa, take it easy sweetheart."
That seems like a sure sign that Farrell's
Penguin role is only getting bigger from here
on out.
But what did it take for Farrell to make such
a striking transformation?
A whole lot, it turns out.
In an interview with Total Film, Colin Farrell
said that there was always going to be more
to his portrayal of the character than the
sheer physicality, although it took finally
seeing the full prosthetic get-up to hammer
home who the Penguin was.
He said:
"I knew where I was going with that, but I
wasn't fully comfortable until I saw the makeup.
When I saw the makeup, it just all became
really, really clear."
Before that, Farrell's preparation had mostly
involved finding the psychology of the Penguin.
In "The Batman," Cobblepot isn't as high on
the criminal hierarchy as he's often depicted
in the comics.
Farrell explained to Total Film that he really
tried to examine where the character is during
the movie, and the journey to full-fledged
Batman villain that he still has ahead of
him.
"Every discussion until I saw what Mike Marino,
the makeup artist, had designed, was considering
the character's psychology and where he was
at this stage of his criminal career."
The makeup and prosthetics involved proved
transformational on such a level that even
most die-hard Farrell fans barely recognized
him when the first trailer for "The Batman"
was released.
Farrell has publicly praised the work of these
artists for helping define the character so
clearly – for audiences as well as for himself
as an actor.
"You know, I could see the history on this
man's face.
I could see what a hard life he'd had.
And just behavior and mannerisms just were
instantly informed."
Under such heavy prosthetics and makeup, it
should come as no surprise that Colin Farrell's
Penguin took hours to prepare — despite
the on-screen character having a relatively
simple costume compared to everyone else in
the movie.
Farrell explained to Total Film:
"Someone was there that had molded the teeth.
Someone was there that had done the hair.
Mike and his team were there, three or four
of them were applying different pieces because
it's six or eight different individual prosthetic
pieces.
And once it all went on, honest to God, it
overtook me, as I think it would most people."
Another drastic change to Colin Farrell's
look is his size.
The Irish-born actor has bulked up for films
like "Total Recall," but he put on the extra
pounds in a very different way for "The Batman."
The weight, however, was a happy accident.
Farrell had just filmed the miniseries "The
North Water," a role for which he'd intentionally
packed on some extra pounds.
When he met with Matt Reeves for "The Batman,"
Reeves loved the look.
As Farrell described the meeting to Total
Film:
"Matt was like, 'Oh, yeah, I love it.
I think that's Oz!'
And I was like, 'Nah, man, let's have a thin
Oz because I'm not feeling great now, I have
to lose this weight.
There's no way I was keeping it on, man.'"
In the end, they compromised: Colin Farrell
got to lose the extra weight, while Reeves
got his Oz through pounds of prosthetics that
took four hours to apply before each shooting
day.
The end result of the transformation was so
convincing that even some of his costars failed
to recognize him.
"Jeffrey Wright walked by me and I said, 'Morning,
man,' and he looked at me like he wanted me
thrown off the set."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.